in June 2016 the gentleman behind the
Reddit account filo fish 1066 made
headlines for getting fired he'd been
working as a software developer at his
company for 6 years where his work
mostly involved testing software in the
quality assurance Department it was
deeply boring all he did was run the
same old tests on the same old software
following the same old scripts every
time so filo fish 1066 came up with a
plan without alerting his boss he spent
the first 8 months of his employment
programming software to automate his job
fop fish 1066 had realized that he might
not have ownership over what he did as
he to do what his boss said but he chose
to take ownership over how he did it
there's a lesson here for us all there's
almost always a way for us to own the
process of a task even when the outcome
has been determined by someone else if
you work in customer service you may not
have control over the company's policies
but you can take ownership of how you
interact with customers if you're a
teacher you may not have control over
the curriculum but you can take
ownership of how you teach the material
there's an extraordinary power to be
gained by doing it your way even in the
most disempowering
circumstances